kevin would you say that you're more
skilled than the magics and the birds
man that's the problem with your meteor
types i could never play bird outside of
like a ripped space time so you all need
to stop with me oh
what the
yo lebron i told you save the space jam
[ __ ]
welcome to the arena outside of space
and time
the only place to explicitly solve
hypothetical debates alongside the man i
currently have ranked seventh greatest
goat of all time 2021 kevin the rant
right katie
was in 2018. this is my personal hero
and a fine man oh great michael
rappaport three-time nba champ 1986 a
larry berry three to eleven win by two
brooklyn well shucks i will [ __ ] up an
aau team i do not care
and third strikes first
how the hell did you get here
my god it's magic magic where
well it was just your seven foot ass
i'm 6 11.
it's built different but in a bad way
with the pickpocket well i'll just shoot
from the bench skinny mother
and katie's thin millennial skin cannot
handle the mind games of larry bird
can't win by himself i need to talk
maniac too let's play ball
[Applause]
there he steals it and hits the layer
katie's just too nice
third passes to bird and bird scores
and katie with an
[Applause]
but we forgot these are two of the
prettiest fellas ever to play the game
one more evenly match than i thought
but i've got a secret
i could play defense if it's absolutely
necessary
he truly is a real one for this two out
of three next time larry legend hey
watch your back oh
all right never mind i just say it i am
better than larry bird
oh man this jakey ass portal sent me to
the wrong year buy tickets support the
team go sonics
man getting out of the stadium sucks
yeah we come all this way across
multiple dimensions and lebron doesn't
even play gotta subscribe to this
channel for more i guess oh finally
here's the train this time train is out
of service